il y a beaucoup de là il y en a des
milliers ah mais là il y en av là
c'était énorme il y a pas que des
punaises d'ailleurs si peut-être ouais
là non là on a rencontré que de la
punaise
alors c'est impressionnant
alors ça j'ai jamais vu de mes propres
yeux quand
[Musique]
même bonjour Bruno Studer député de la
3e circonscription du barrain ici à
Strasbourg pour suivre un sujet sur
lequel je travaille depuis 2018 à voir
la lutte contre les punaises de
lit en Alsace autour de Strasbourg on
connaît bien la problématique des
punaises de lit d'abord parce que c'est
une des régions les plus infestées de
France mais aussi parce que le député
Bruno Studer n'a pas attendu la
véritable psychose des punaises qui a
envahi notre pays cette automne pour
s'intéresser au sujet ce jour-là il se
rend dans une résidence étudiante pour
savoir si cette année il y a eu ou non
une recrudescence du phénomène bonjour
monsieur enchanté enchanté bien car ici
on suit le problème de très près avec
les allées venu d'étudiants on connaît
bien les punaises de lit c'est la
période effectivement de la rentrée où
on a bah le plus de de cas de punaises
parce que il y a forcément des nouveaux
arrivants qui viennent avec leur punaise
nouveau et c'est pas nouveau non c'est
pas nouveau c'est un phénomène régulier
c'est un les punis c'est c'est
structurel dans une résidence telle que
la nôtre puisque effectivement le mode
de transmission ça va être les bagages
il y a eu un emballement médiatique qui
semblait correspondre à une réalité de
terrain moi je me suis attaché à dire
qu'en fait c'est un phénomène qu'on ne
connaît pas trop vous par exemple ici
plus ou moins de punaisse de lit en 2023
par rapport à 2022 alors non moins moins
que l'an dernier on a traité 49 chambres
et studio et cette année on est pour
l'instant à 39 on devrait finir
peut-être au grand maximum à 42 43 donc
on aura une une baisse sensible c'est
d'ailleurs tout l'intérêt d'avoir pour
vous des statistiques qu'on a pas au
niveau national c'est que ben on peut
dire ici dans le cru bah il y a pas plus
voilà peut-être il y a des endroits il y
en a plus peut-être moins et c'est ce
qui manque en fait au niveau national
c'est qu'on n pas d'outil qui nous
permett de savoir de quoi on parle en
fait le député vient voir ce que le cru
a mise en place pour obtenir ses bons
résultats
dès qu'une chambre a la moindre punaise
elle est traitée avec des insecticides
dédiés et l'étudiant doit transporter
toutes ses affaires au
sous-sol ah la vache c'est une vraie
chambre fro c'est en fait les mêmes
chambres froid qu'on utilise dans les
resto mais là vous allez
voir forcémentit un peu froidz on traite
par exemple des
matelas par le passé on jet les matelas
grâce à la chambre froide on peut tout
simplement juste traiter les housses ou
les matelas et les remettre en
circulation parce qu'on a la certitude
que au bout de 3 jours les les punais
c'est étud et al ça c'est les affaires
des étudiants là c'est une chambre 2 3 4
ça c'est une valise de 5 6 7 8 allez
V les meubles où les punaises aiment se
cacher ont aussi été un peu
remplacés dans ce bâtiment donc le
bâtiment où il y a essentiellement des
chambres on avait une literie bois avec
des planches qui étaient non protégées
c'est-à-dire que les les punaises
pouvaient se s'insérer facilement donc
on remplace au fur et à mesure aussi par
des lit métal de manière préventive et
ça a plutôt des bons résultats Bruno
Studer souhaiterait dans sa loi demander
aux personnes qui font du rbnb de
diffuser des mesures de précaution
auprès des voyageurs aujourd'hui
peut-être l'angle mort c'est les meublés
de tourisme c'est peut-être là que la
loi a un intérêt sur quelle contrainte
on peut faire peser sur voilà les
personnes qui font du meubl de tourisme
donc qui voi passer des dizaines de
personnes dans le même logement à
l'année peut-être là il y a-t-il des
obligation d'information en tout cas à
mettre en place mais avant tout le
député est persuadé qu'il faudrait
compter répertorier cartographier les
cas pour pouvoir agir et sa loi
s'adresse au professionnels plus qu'au
particulier en mettant en avant la
détection des punaises un secteur qu'il
connaît bien
bonjour bonjour monsieur le député ça va
et vous ou ça fait plaisir Deir salut
est-ce que c'est celle que j'avaiselle
vous avez
V le député s'active aussi depuis 3 ans
pour que le secteur s'organise afin
d'éviter les acteurs qui s'improvis
spécialistes du
métier sans être
vraiment
bonjour tour chez vous ce matin donc
elle est déjà très intéressée elle sait
pourquoi elle est là donc là on est sur
une suspici ce matin vous avez présenté
des des piqûes des piqures ouais mais ça
ça fait assez longtemps mais suite à ça
il y avait pas eu d'autres signne
jusqu'à ce qu'on découvre une punun sur
un fauteuil en pleine journée un
dimanche ok en 2019 quand moi j'ai fait
les premières réunions à l'assemblé
national c'était les balbuements de la
filière depuis on a eu des
certifications pour les entre puisquil
font des traitements et là la filière
déction est en train de s'organiser
encore une fois c'est clé la détection
c'est vraiment la première étape surtout
sur phénomènes
[Musique]
isol trace son chemin dans
l'appartement dans la chambre des
enfants elle ne détecte
rien
ok en revanche près du lit des parents
pas de doute là elle m'a fait un
marquage elle bougeait plus elle a
montré avec son pif où était situé
l'odeur source ça veut dire qu'il y a
des des puness de l vivante qui sont
situé dans la zone où elle a
marqué une détection qui va coûter près
de 300 € à la cliente sans compter le
traitement s'il en faut un le député
aurait bien aimé que assurance puisse
rembourser ses frais et couvrir les
risques punais de lit mais pour le
moment il y a un hic ok les assurances
aujourd'hui elles nous disent que pour
produire des pour proposer des des
produits d'assurance B il faut connaître
le phénomène pour savoir le quantifier
pour savoir combien on va
demander aux assurés de de de mettre au
pot par rapport à ce que ça peut
éventuellement coûter ok finalement la
cliente s'en sort avec un traitement
assez simple il y a bien eu un marquage
de de de de punaise donc des punaises de
l vivantes sont sont sont présentes je
vous rassure on est vraiment sur une
infestation naissante très localisé donc
ça va être relativement facile à traiter
si les bons leviers sont sont sont
actionnés et les bonnes actions sont
mises en place surtout pas de traitement
chimique vous-même ça c'est très
important même les packaging qu'on peut
trouver spécial punaise choc punais et
cetera pas d'insecticide vous-même bon
ça pas l'air d'être votre
démarche mais tout ce qui va être B
traitement du linge traitement vapeur et
cetera vous pouvez le faire vous-même
moi j'ai déjà beaucoup de particuliers
sur une infestation comme la vôtre qui
sont arrivé en louant un appareil vapeur
ou autre on a beaucoup de gens qui des
plateformes et cetera des entreprises
même maintenant qui commence à louer des
alors moi j'ai pas trouvé j'ai cherché
j'ai pas trouvé de machine à louer on
commence en avoir je vous donnerai deux
trois références si vous voulez
là-dessus mais voilà c'est quelque chose
que vous vous pouvez
commencer alors pour mesurer le
phénomène la proposition de loi portée
par le député alsacien va imposer aux
entreprises qui interviennent pour la
détection et la désinfection de signaler
les habitations
concernées le choix n'a pas été fait de
rendre cela obligatoire pour les foyers
eux-mêmes qui dit obligation dit
sanction moi j'ai pas envie de créer une
nouvelle amende pour les gens qui
n'oseraient pas déclarer et on peut
comprendre pourquoi on peut ne pas
vouloir déclarer parce que ça peut avoir
un impact sur sa vie sociale que ce soit
au sein de l'immeuble mais aussi au-delà
je pense que c'est une obligation qui a
faire peser sur les entreprises parce
que c'est elles aussi qui vivent euh
enfin qui font leur leur leur chiffre
d'affaires là-dessus donc c'est à elle
qu'on peut faire poser des obligations
et pas sur les particuliers qui ont déjà
assez de problèmes comme ça mais quand
l'infestation devient invasion les
traitements peuvent être très onéreux
bonjour bonjour ça va ça va bien et vous
alors on va s'attaquer au punaise c'est
ça on va faire un petit traitement de
punaise de
lit est-ce là vous savez exactement où
elles sont vous alors ils ont le alors
tout se passe autour du luit apparemment
tout été ciblé là autour du lit ce
studio a déjà subi deux traitement
chimique mais rien n'y fait les punaises
sont toujours là même si la journée on
ne les voit pas la chambre est pleine
d'indice de leur passage donc là on peut
dester quelques trases de déjection la
punaise ça c'est une trace de sang quoi
une punaise qui a été écrasée en fait
donc voilà ça c'est du sang et donc on
peut on peut voilà on peut ça nous
laisse croire quand même qu'il y a une
manifestation quand même qui est quand
même déjà assez élevé au grands mot les
grands
remèdes c'est donc le traitement
thermique qui a été choisi la pièce va
être surchauffée pendant 4 He atteignant
les punaes qui se cachent dans des
endroits les plus
inattendus tout reste en place tout va
chauffer làel de 60° puis voilà c'est
l'avantage en fait de la du traitement
par l'air un chaud et c'est tout laissé
sur place et là y compris à l'intérieur
du question de volet ça va chauffer à
isolé voilà tout va tout tout tout va
chauffer d'accord les photos ça craint
rien ça ça craint rien es vont courber
mais elles vont se remettre après ah oui
d'accord ça va se courber se courber ça
se remettra après automatiquement
d'accord donc on peut lancer on est prêt
alors on y va
tac là vous allez voir le brûleur qui va
se mettre en route une chusière on va
l'entendre c'est ça et donc là ça va
commencer à monter en température en
fait en une seule fois la chaleur va
tuer tous les insectes un traitement
exceptionnel sans les inconvénients de
la chimie car le locataire va pouvoir
réintégrer son logement dans quelques
heures mais un traitement
coûteux 1500 € pour ce studio de moins
de 30
m² pour un appartement standard le prix
aussi entre 3000 et 5 000
€ car les équipements sont encore rares
10ine comme ça il y en a combien en
France il y a deux machines en France
deux il y a une machine qui est dans le
sud de la France avec un confrère ok qui
l' acheté en même temps que nous et la N
et bientôt une troisème machine et alors
c'est quoi les limites à l'utilisation
c'est quoi c'est la hauteur c'est le
nombre d'étage à un moment donné on peut
traiter avec cette machine là un
logement d'une superficie d'à peu près
120 m² mais si mais pas au 15e étage on
peut monter la pompe nous permet de
monter jusqu'au 20e étage sans aucun
problème
d'accord si les traitements chimiques
sont deux fois moins cher que les
traitements thermiques leur prix reste
tout de même important c'est pourquoi
Bruno Studer a demandé au gouvernement
un geste financier le budget de l'État a
prévu 5 millions d'euros pour aider les
ménages les moins aisés à payer les
traitements dans sa loi le député
propose aussi dans des cas extrêmes
d'élargir les possibilités des maires de
forcer les habitants à ouvrir et traiter
leurs logement pour éviter les
infestations massives la première des
choses c'est lever le frein financier
c'estd que même avant la proposition de
loi dans le projet de loi de finance il
y a C la création de ce fond pour les
collectivités auquel les particuliers
peuvent faire appel et après c'est aussi
une manière de dire bah voilà nous on
met en place des aides et puis si malgré
tout les gens ne veulent pas ouvrir bien
effectivement on peut passer à une autre
étape un peu plus contraignante à la
main des maires pour faire ouvrir
à quelques mois de l'organisation des
Jeux Olympiques à Paris l'enjeu est
important en septembre dernier de
nombreux médias étrangers
s'intéressaient au sort des touristes
qui pourraient ramener ces punaises dans
leur pays d'origine en l'espace de 10
ans le nombre d'infestations en France
aurait été multiplié par
[Musique]